hundreds of Morsi supporters barricaded
themselves inside Kairos alfetta mosque
seeking refuge from both armed vigilante
groups and army backed security forces
outside the standoff around the House of
Prayer lasted for hours but then the gun
battle began crowds panicked as shots
rang out witnesses say Muslim
Brotherhood sharpshooters fired at
security forces from a mosque minaret as
soldiers returned fire chaos spiraled
again all attempts at finding a peaceful
resolution came to naught at a news
conference interim Prime Minister Albert
lui refused to press for reconciliation
there's no reconciliation with those who
have blood on their hands there's no
reconciliation with anyone who has taken
up arms against our country and its
citizens the macheted now hundreds have
died in the past four days of violence
thousands more have been injured or
arrested yet both sides remain resolute
the government now proposes disbanding
an outlawing morsi's Muslim Brotherhood
party and the Brotherhood has vowed to
continue its protests in the coming week